let's now talk about the Trump approval
rating on coronavirus hint it has
absolutely imploded now you might
remember a few weeks ago now I guess
really like three three and a half weeks
ago earlier in the corona virus pandemic
we saw that Donald Trump was sporting a
pretty healthy approval rating when it
came to his handling of the virus and we
were wondering why and most likely it
was a few things that were sort of
booing for lack of a better term Donald
Trump's approval rating in general and
on the virus number one there was the
sort of rally around the president
factor which is often in play early in a
crisis where you have more people than
agree with the president politically say
I support the president and they're
doing a good job at least so far you
also three and a half weeks ago had a
whole bunch of US states that didn't
have many cases so there were many more
people in the country that could feel
rightly or wrongly like it was under
control because their state didn't have
many cases now of course it is a virus
meaning it spreads virally we now have
13 states with more than 5,000 cases we
have 30 states with more than a thousand
cases and every single state other than
Wyoming has had deaths
so both the reality of rally around the
president and the reality of my state's
doing fine both of those things have
changed they've faded and the
disapproval now of Trump on the virus is
up nine points it was 43 percent
disapproval in mid-march it is up to 52
percent disapproval that's a climb of
more than 20 percent and if things keep
going the way they're going both in
terms of the numbers and in terms of
Trump's unhinged response I would expect
that disapproval on Trump's handling of
the virus is going to keep going up the
rally around the flag rally around the
leader stuff is very common but it
doesn't last forever and we have had one
of the worst responses total we are
testing per capita 39 in the world trump
regularly claims we are doing the most
tests per capita we're not really sure
he understands what per capita me
but he claims that we're doing the most
tests per capita Trump insults reporters
at press conferences who ask real
questions Trump attacks media outlets
Trump recommends dangerous behavior
suggests medications during press
conferences brags about dating models
during his press briefings and every day
we are continuing to see more and more
states have these bigger and bigger
numbers of cases eventually it was bound
to affect his approval now a few things
to keep in mind number one this kind of
piggybacks on our earlier story about
the World Mental Health coalition
demanding Trump be removed number one
Trump's approval on coronavirus may keep
going down if his handling of the virus
remains poor but the power of cults is
very strong and Trump has a powerful
cult around him that is going to support
him no matter what we're gonna get to
that a little bit later with some
examples but just like Jim Jones got his
followers to drink cyanide laced
kool-aid Trump's followers are going to
keep insisting that Trump is handling
this well just like Trump says he's
doing during his own press briefings so
we can only expect his approval to fall
a little bit more because of that
cultish support around him number two
there will be no consequences to Donald
Trump's mishandling of this crisis
unless we remove him in November which
means voting he's not going to be
impeached he's not going to be removed
by the 25th amendment none of it so is
it good that Trump's approval on
coronavirus is coming down instead of
going up yeah of course it's good it
means some of the people in this country
are at least tangentially tied to
reality but Trump's response to the
virus has been diabolical and depraved
and to see disapproval after two months
at only 52% is incredibly disturbing and
so we just need to be realistic in our
expectations death toll goes up they
claim the death toll isn't accurate we
started seeing that last week cases
spike wildly they claim it's only
because our testing is so good and so
widespread so we've got to remember they
will always talk their way
of any piece of data that we can present
and we can only expect the approval to
fall so much because of the cult of
personality around Donald Trump and a
little bit later in the show I will have
some stunning stunning video of some of
these cultists that you won't believe or
maybe you will believe if you've been
watching this show and paying attention
to the news for the last few years
want to remind you Thursday this
Thursday April 9 we are doing a 1-day
membership bomb we lost three hundred
and eighty-nine members in March the
most we've ever seen canceled and it's
because of the tightening of the belt
around the virus we understand it
everybody is in a many people are in a
precarious situation so we get it so the
idea is this Thursday we're gonna do a
one-day membership special biggest
discount of the year if you want to be
notified by email of the membership
discount code grab a mailing list
subscription for free at david
pakman.com just sign up for our mailing
list this Thursday 2:00 p.m. Eastern
11:00 a.m. Pacific an email will go out
with a code and the idea is we've
already lost a bunch of members early in
April we lost 389 in March we want to
try to do something cohesive and
community oriented to try to bring back
some of that support we're all in this
thing together
get on that mailing list to david
pakman.com in the meantime let me know
on twitter are you watching trump's
press briefings on the virus every day
most days once a week never I want to
hear from you I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
check this out the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months completely free skill shares the
online learning community with thousands
of classes on almost anything you can
imagine always taught by experts they
have classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
running a small business and much more I
recently took a very interesting class
called simple productivity how to
accomplish more with less and got a
bunch of gray
personal productivity tips out of it we
should allow ourselves a little time
every week to either get creative keep
your brain sharp learn something new
it's great for mental health and almost
all the classes are under an hour so
it's very easy for someone who's busy to
take advantage of it with skill share
you can discover a new passion explore
something you didn't know you would
enjoy but there's also plenty of classes
for people with experience so you can
just get better at something you're
already good at and again the first 500
people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two whole months giving you access to
every class Skillshare offers check it
out I put the link right underneath this
video